discriminación y violencia dificultades
que tuvieron que atravesar estudiantes
africanos que residían en ucrania para
salir del país los jóvenes grabaron la
travesía que iniciaron cuando decidieron
ir a la abarrotada estación de tren de
jarquín para huir de la guerra luego de
soportar semanas de bombardeos más
adelante en la frontera esperaron más de
14 horas de pie para poder cruzar a
rumanía
recuerdo haber pensado cuando estaba
justo frente a la puerta es aquí donde
muero porque no tenía más energía y
estaba a punto de desmayarme pero
seguiré por lo compactos que estábamos
it's just to people los africanos deben
pelear por un puesto en los trenes o
caminar hasta las fronteras algunos
estudiantes que encontraron refugio en
una iglesia en alemania aseguran que
dejan pasar a pocos extranjeros mientras
que los ucranianos tienen vía libre
y puedo decir que hubo discriminación
éramos un grupo de extranjeros y
ucranianos fue fácil para los ucranianos
entrar a polonia pero no para los
extranjeros nosotros ni siquiera
podíamos cruzar los estudiantes son
atraídos a las universidades de ucrania
desde la guerra fría por las políticas
de educación subsidiada más de 4000
nigerianos se encontraban en el país
cuando estalló la guerra y son el
segundo grupo más numeroso de
extranjeros después de los marroquíes
que alcanzan los 8000 a principios de
marzo el consejo de seguridad de la onu
rechazó la discriminación en contra de
los africanos que intentan salir de
ucrania pero los testimonios afirman que
la problemática continua